hello you tell me your name i'll tell  you mine  why do you want to know my name i want  to know who i'm looking at  that first screen will always be looked  up to and looked back at we knew we were  part of something that felt like it was  on fire  sid it's happening again  we can't do this new scream justice if  all three don't come back i read the  script it was quick and sharp and funny  and scary  this film feels like the first cream  really excited for nev to come back  where she's like this badass  i won't sleep until he's in the ground  we see a lot of dewey in this film it's  really nice to see his journey  i'm really excited for audiences to see  these characters that they've loved and  to see how they've progressed  when dewey and gail intersect it was  perfect really emotional  fans always asked me to make another one  it's fun to get into it again and it's  really scary  i've seen this movie before not this  movie sydney  [Applause]  [Music]  you